[Music]
[Music]
my name is Rick Brown owner of venture
sixty north Adventure Center in Seward
Alaska
I've been guiding here since the early
90s I've lived here permanently since
2003 and have been guiding in the
glaciers all that time
normally I think that Park will tell you
that it retreats about 150 feet per year
right now they're looking at 10 to 15
feet per day
you're seeing the big crevasses that
used to be blue up on top of the
compression zones now down in the Toyota
glacier just falling over
something that normally would take
hundreds of years we're seeing probably
in a matter of a year or two we're just
watching the transformation happened in
front of our eyes right now
as you drive into our park you'll see
the signs that mark different points
where the glacier had traveled during
the 1800s all the way back to the early
nineteen hundred's
things that used to take hundreds of
years is actually now only taken months
we're seeing a change in the wildlife
we have villages that are being
relocated
we get storms up here that if they were
happening down in the lower 48 we name
them something
our ten-year floods are happening every
other year now
you can drive to our town and look at
what's going on and if you can't see
what's happening then I think that you
must be blind
[Music]
we're running a snowcat out here
normally I would need a plow here in my
office and we needed a lot more
[Music]
I
hope that the people that come to Alaska
to visit us they take time to try to
understand what it is they're seeing
this place will not stay the same is
going to be different but I just hope
that we just learned how to take care of
it
[Music]
you know I have four daughters and a
bunch of grandkids as I sit here and
talk about this I wonder what they will
see if they come back after I'm gone
that's my concern is for the future
wondering how this climate thing is
going to work out for them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]